the amount of people in this room that
believe they have a story to tell they
make a video or have something to say
and then use social media as
distribution is by a high percentage
most people here look at Facebook and
Twitter as distribution channels I'm
going to do something over here I'm
going to take the link and I'm going to
post it on Facebook consider and drive
people they treat social like email
marketing with a completely lack and
where all the upside is and what I
basically wrote about in the book is
storytelling contextually within it so
the results happen within it no reason
to send a mouse somewhere else people I
mean people really get an emotional
romantic point of view of driving people
out of social to their website so their
website can do their thing when at the
end of the day is long I mean would you
care if you sold somebody in your house
or at the park doesn't really matter as
long as you sold them and so there's
just a lack of strategy in my opinion
what by the way one man's point of view
one man's point of view that spends all
his time thinking about why in the world
are my friends raising a million dollars
starting a company and then heavily
hurting companies that have 500 million
dollars in market cap why are we living
in that world right now why are we
living in a world where companies within
36 months are able to massively disrupt
the incumbent that has so much more
money and so much more legacy so much
more brand equity and so much more
infrastructure and it's happening
because the internet itself the Internet
itself has eliminated the costs of
infrastructure to go to the consumer and
story-tell in an efficient way and in a
quick way and meanwhile what I spend all
my time in not trying to allow my
customers to spend money on dumb [ __ ]
because that's what they do all day long
we're spending money on dumb [ __ ] and
we're not storytelling to where the
consumer is and this is happening at
scale the fastest growing demo for 40 to
60 year olds right now is the fastest
growing demo on Instagram it serums
fastest growing demo is a forty to six
year old the people that are taking the
most selfies in the
growth curve in the last six months our
forty three point three year old females
forty three year old females are the
highest growth curve in selfies moms are
[ __ ] pulling it out and snapping the
[ __ ] at a selfies at a scale that nobody
thought and so we're disregarding a very
important fact one I want to really
pound this one home for you I really
want you to hear this one because way
too many people are gonna pull the when
my customers not they are card or my
demos not there that's a favorite
[ __ ] card that I want to [ __ ] burn
right now let me explain to you what's
going on with your [ __ ] card right
your my customers not there let's talk
about that the highest conversion of
consumption on Facebook right now is 46
to 63 year olds because it got into the
habit and they're not leaving it's why
your mom still has a yahoo email address
right that kind of [ __ ] number two
number two if you look at the behavioral
data the clothes she buys the way she
goes out and how often her routine the
way she engages on social right now the
average and this is an American step so
I don't have a freaking I apologize the
average bless you the average the
average forty four-year-old female in
the US behavior
maps to the average twenty nine-year-old
American woman its behavior only 10
years ago we are living through the
youth of vacation of our society for
anybody here over thirty five forty they
can remember their parents at some point
at that age everybody in here that's
capable of it
think for one second right now of your
parent at the age you are right now and
I promise you they were much older than
you their behavior was much older we're
living through a massive unification and
it's because of the shift in technology
how many people here have a daughter or
son that's fifteen to twenty two years
old raise your hands thank you so for
the thirty of you do you remember the
conversation you had two years ago when
you said hey little Ricky I don't care
how you talk to your friends but when
your mother and father call you pick up
the damn phone remember that one just
curious
how'd that work out for you let me
explain to the rest of crowd how it
worked out
they're a grown-ass men in this room
in their 50s that texted lol and oMG in
the last 24 hours
that's what happened Uncle Bob's like
where's my emoji Kon right so shit's
changing and it's funny to laugh and
it's interesting to watch and you're
seeing it anecdotally in your life
you're going out you're seeing it you're
seeing it you're tasting it and you're
disregarding it in your execution in
your marketing and running your
businesses it's just the way it is and
honestly I know there's a huge crossover
near I know there's a twenty to forty
percent of this audience that knows it
sees it but can't do anything about it
because as the layers go up it gets
killed somewhere along line because
there's no ROI
there's no belief in it it's not safe
you can't do it still doesn't stop from
it being wrong